[Applause]
right
nice to see you the cherry oliver
brigade how are you feeling
i'm feeling really good who's the most
talented cook in the brigade
truthfully come on it's not now
it's one of these things i'm worried
already nobody knows no you know what it
is
we cook together meet tonight's family
brigade the cherry olivers
singer naina cherry is joined by best
friend tv and radio broadcaster
andy oliver these soul sisters love
nothing more than cooking for friends
and loved ones andy's nephew marcus is
rarely allowed in the kitchen by
girlfriend babs
a fashion designer who'll find work into
my kitchen anything but glamorous
on the menu tonight smoked trout
riyettes
glazed beef with gremolata and a
delicious pear to tan
[Music]
right smoke trout yes creme fraiche what
else goes in there
the horseradish good the little gherkins
good right yeah chopped
and they're chives yes little touch of
salt pepper so we're gonna mix that up
yeah yeah fresh chives
and this is just about the combination
of flavours yeah
our smoked trout it's um incredibly
packed with protein it's healthy
we'll flake that through nice large
flakes yeah the baby gherkins okay
right gives a really nice sharpness to
the richness of the creme fraiche
combined with the horseradish
yeah every time you use smoked salmon
smoked out you always use lemon juice
yeah
yeah just to help sort of keep
everything vibrant mix that up
right that's right you can see the
bottom of the spatula yeah i'm just
folding that in there like that
i'm not coming here otherwise it becomes
nice
yeah mushy and very pasty okay a lettuce
off of the root why are you cutting the
the little
good question there's one they meet in
the middle they sit neater on the plate
look at the center of the plate yeah
okay and tonight of course everyone's
coming to pay for dinner i gotta call it
a trip if you take the bomb with at
least
it will make kind of a mistake
okay a little bit of mousse in not too
much
any excess yeah that's right we want to
feed them
and not stuff them somewhere now wet one
spoon
lift it up easier to drop off again take
off any excess
i'm just rolling that round just a
little touch of lemon juice
on about two droplets yeah that kicks
everything weight it all up
touch of peace shoot as it hits the hot
plate bang
wow beautiful okay have a little taste
yeah
get cleaned up and then we'll start
marcus nina you work together yeah andy
babs work together yes
that is so good and you get that
horseradish but it's not too strong at
all
it's really good this is some good stuff
man
right on your sections and we'll get
going yes right guys on order here is
the first ticket
six covers table nine six trout six v
six tatan
thank you nina once you've made it
taste it yeah yeah so you know you're
happy with it yes yes
what's your real name yeah
it's a lovely name where
oh
59 days too long jesus christ
yep right taste markers uh i don't know
which plates are it's not bad it's
actually what
not bad [ __ ] me that's not good enough
that he's not good enough would you mind
not licking your fingers as well
okay nice those cornells are beautiful
right come here would you pay for that
olive oil i hope so yeah yeah yes or no
because they look fantastic
right in america wild boar are running
riot so
i thought i'd join them there's a corner
of georgia being torn to pieces by wild
hog
but they've picked the wrong patch fort
benning
home to more than 30 000 american
soldiers and for the next few days
me
[Music]
this is the third largest military base
in the whole of america
but the hot population down there is
causing chaos
they're ripping up the roads and ruining
the forest and the problem is so bad
the commander general has put a bounty
on their heads this could be my toughest
challenge so far
hog is lean tender and bursting with
flavor
to give me the chance of tasting some
delicious prime cuts from the wild
i'm joining the army special task force
under the command
of major bobby toon major
how are you howdy good to see you good
now how difficult are these hogs
big fast furious very fast and delicious
they're very
yeah they taste very good free pork
can't beat it chances are catching one
the chances of us seeing one and
encountering pigs tomorrow i would say
is probably 80 to 85
the chances of you being able to close
the deal are you cooling this [ __ ] sean
no i'm just saying that's why we're here
tonight to make sure
everything goes properly absolutely to
keep the hog population down there's a
40
reward for any shot on the base i'll be
aiming for mine with a powerful
long-range rifle
[ __ ] settle your crosshairs yeah exhale
god it's so difficult that in there yep
that's a money shot you see it yeah
handguns are used for protection and to
kill any hogs in traps
but they were alien to me
and it showed tomorrow morning yeah
we'll stick with the long rifle yeah
definitely
[Laughter]
sod the pistol
we started our search the following day
at 6 00 a.m
let's go hunt for a pig the first lesson
was how to trap the pigs
through the forest what is that this is
pig's cat right there pig [ __ ] i'm
trying to use the biological name but
you're correct sir
that would be [ __ ] it's the hog damage
here
that's led to the army's decision to
cull them in order to stop the numbers
from spiraling out of control
[Music]
you can see where the pigs they dig in
the sand
i mean it's like there's been a almost
like a bomb exploded here it's like a
fallout isn't it
yes i can't believe how much damage
they're causing they eat all the
nutrients they eat all the bugs eat all
the roots and all the tubers
out of the ground having walked four
kilometers it was getting harder to keep
a sense of direction
but signs of a pig trail kept our
confidence high
you see this this uh these places where
there's mud
yeah that's from a pig i smell it
you can kind of smell pig and the pigs
came across this creek and they ripped
them out okay
you can't smell that yeah so that's his
ass rubbing against the
tree i wasn't gonna tell you that but
you're correct yes yeah that's the pigs
yeah derriere rubbing against the tree
two hours in
and still nothing the hogs always seem
one step ahead
but then
[Music]
right there yeah [ __ ] come on come on
come on
[Music]
but they were too quick for our camera
and the sights of my rifle
[ __ ] oh that's exciting in there i can't
believe how fast they move
so did we spook them well yeah they
smelled this earth they hurt us
they saw us or something we're
definitely get that pig i am not going
to give up
let's go
marcus yep you okay yep good stay on top
of the big boy yes
have you said a date yet uh marcus have
we said day four yes
[Applause]
marcus they don't come swimming past
like that
you know she's beautiful yeah obviously
partially blind but beautiful
some lemon's ready there how many more
all right service table 10 here please
yes
[Music]
and that is the last table yes
hi well done
translatus really went well with it with
the fish so really good all in all
right how was your start it was strong
there was too much
too much radish in terms of the power
the
[Laughter]
and the sauce itself was very salty
so i'm not going to be paying for the
dish results for the starters yes
right josie let's go okay right andy how
do you think you've done i
think i think we did quite well we
warmed up we got into them we got to
flow and i think that
you know the more confident we got the
better the place and i think we did a
good job actually
there are customers that have agreed to
pay
[Music]
43 out of 15. 43 out of 50.
wait wait wait wait we still have got
the beef to go yeah that's right
hey stop but marcus that's really a
great start i'm very impressed yes
don't [ __ ] it up on the main course okay
let's go
next up there's another disaster for the
labour party
pauline sorry for [ __ ] your oven
don't worry gordon you're going
down and get some fish and chips no
you're not going to die i get fishing
tubes
and i finally get my hands on a wild
boar you know what you have in your hand
right there gordon
that's uh that's one of those testicles
[Applause]
time for the main course pan roasted
glazed fillets of beef with pompore and
spinach
andy chase takes taste so it's a beef
one of my favorite
cuts of all time packed with flavor salt
pepper hot pan olive oil
make sure you get a really nice color on
the steaks
garlic rosemary thyme
bay leaf chicken stock
the secret is to keep them nice and
moist
rest whilst the steak's absorbing the
stock i'm going to make the gremolata
lemon zest parsley
capers season mix
so packed with flavor beef
carved
[Music]
gremolata
[Music]
sauce olive oil that has to be the most
perfect way
of eating a philly steak [ __ ]
delicious
pan roasted fillet of beef with
gremolata
done right six away
yes what are we doing
and be careful when you squash them down
yeah because you'll flatten them and
then okay they'll over cook
all right i'm gonna work with the tea
now
[Applause]
put one spoon in mix it in and then mix
the rest in yeah good girl andy have you
seasoned it
touch tell me this spring in the middle
now yeah on top
no it's going to straight through that
means it's not cooked
as it gives you the spring yeah and
bouncing back up yeah the heat's gone
through to the middle
yeah that's there there's no spring so
that tells you
it's raw perfect they are beautiful done
well done so where are we now face what
do we need where are we
we need spinach okay where's your pan
with spinach my spinach pan for this
finish you're coming up right take care
of
this
okay so spinach
in good man more more more more there
you go naina
you want to slice the beef please finish
it yeah flat side down look at that
yeah yeah so i'll put the meat back on
to warm yeah out
look from there on beautiful oh it's not
too
really nice and careful with your plates
you just don't service please
this year i'm on a mission to get
everyone cooking healthy food and i mean
everyone
[Music]
i'm in rain-soaked hull to meet
ex-deputy prime minister john prescott
a political heavyweight who often hit
the headlines
a local man chucked an egg at him john
prescott immediately swung round and
landed a punch straight on his jaw
presa our political bruiser is a very
busy man so he thinks that he hasn't got
time to eat well so
i'm going to meet him down at his local
chippy to find out a little bit more
hull is famous for seafood but it's
obvious that john loves it a little bit
too much
john hi sir how are you where are you
i know gordon now normally i'd go and
meet you know guests in their house or
at work but you're here i'm eating you
chicken they're in here you're living
here
um have you invested in the place no i
haven't you have got to taste a piece of
that chest i think
that is fresh fish take a little bit
right first thing my mother taught is
even never speak with a mouthful
you've blown that one so what fish is it
it's haddock okay
that's nice very nice we've been to your
local chipping yeah now we're gonna go
to the local fish monger
buy something raw john surprised the
nation recently when he revealed his
struggle with bulimia
showing that binge eating is a problem
that can affect absolutely anyone
i wanted to find out exactly why he'd
developed this disorder
the job and the responsibility as deputy
prime minister what's far more important
than eating
oh absolutely you never got chance to
eat properly yeah and i took it even
further really that bulimia problem has
just increased the
kind of pressure on eating lots of
things that was
a big shock to everybody that's because
people think they're kind of weak
nobody's ever thought of me as a weak
character
i was being sick constantly in junior by
myself and the other thing was your
glands began to
uh swell from the acid coming up you
didn't like other people to see your
meeting a lot
you know and um so i i couldn't just
sort of work this out and then
of course i picked up what he was doing
you know
and it was happening for quite quite a
long time i had suspicions
as any family member would but very
difficult
because you don't see him that often
food has become a source of guilt and
discomfort for john
i'm going to show him a low calorie
recipe that could become a source of joy
how are we ladies nice to see you have
you got any salmon
and some smoked haddock please daddy
uh yes please naturally smoke yeah that
way john has not died you know it's not
uh
absolutely yeah now is the salmon wow
salmon this is a farm salmon but it's an
open pen salmon so
the whole thing becomes a lot more
tastier less fatty
and better quality trying to get him
healthy
[Music]
onto john's house to meet pauline and
his son john jr and to get the old man
cooking
certain house rules right right you
understand that please far away
no swearing in the kitchen yes that's
you and i [ __ ] straight away
politicians are famous for not sticking
to the point so in order to hold john's
interest
this dish will combine some of his
favorite ingredients
fish cakes is the perfect dish for a man
who loves fish and potatoes
and is less than half the calories of
his beloved fish and chips
cook the potatoes and poach the fish
season some water with lemon fresh thyme
salt and pepper now start off with the
salmon first and we'll put the head
again
potatoes and go straight into the pan
i'm gonna make a very very
quick light vinaigrette to go with the
fish cakes
chopped shallots anchovies
flat leaf parsley mixed together with
capers and olive oil
now just lightly heat that up fish is
ready see how quick that takes
it's a lot easier to flake this when
it's nice and warm all right tis on this
yeah
drain off the potatoes and mash through
so we're gonna add the potatoes
to the fish season with salt pepper
chopped parsley and chervil
and lemon naturally seasons the salmon
and the haddock
so are you over the bulimia now are you
under
yeah well i think a lot of people have
got to recognize it's like alcoholic if
you started to doing and eating and
eating what i will do now
i live with the discomfort rather than
relieving it right
so how do you say how do you say stop in
terms of you know what's coming stuff
you know it's coming
so it's discipline really it's
discipline
while the fish cakes chill prepare their
coating look out
eggs i get nervous when i see eggs
i'm nervous that whole thing happens so
quickly i thought what pasty hit me and
it was warm and i only realized that one
there like that yeah just there
so i was thinking this blood coming down
so my only reaction was to connect with
him because tony had told us to connect
with the electorate
so i give him a left touch
cut the chilled fish cakes and seasoned
flour egg wash and then breadcrumb
oh [ __ ] is this where we say the oven's
[ __ ]
damn i've spilled some water and i've
fused the oven
pauline sorry for [ __ ] your oven
don't worry gordon you don't need
to get some fresh and chips no you're
not gonna die you're fishing tubes
with the oven out of action i'm
improvising and grilling instead
fell beautiful oh no gordon that really
is lovely despite the difficulties it's
lovely
happy with that yeah absolutely
fantastic um for the big one you take
the small one
yeah can't sell them in the bag can you
this is properly eaten follow me my love
now you'll notice there's no batter on
the outside
top drawer can i just say healthy in a
way it's a nice alternative
keeps you happy because you're a big fan
of haddock on the back of that
experience this afternoon
knowing how quick it is to do it i'm
going to continue to do them
truthfully am i going to eat positively
like that yes
if you want to keep balanced about these
things right now and then you can have
fish and chips once
70 years of age you still can't answer a
[ __ ] question straight
just give me a yes or [ __ ] no
right autonomous recipes on the website
so get clicking
that start plating yes right come on
guys
babs marcus yeah we have to speed up now
yeah put them on the plate that is
cooked beautifully yeah
gremolata please chef do i add anything
to the spinach besides butter yeah
no salt and pepper and marcus look at me
you know this you're panicking slow down
okay big deep breath
good girl exit go table four
how's main course fantastic yes did you
enjoy the philippines
very good what did you enjoy most about
it it was so tender and so easy to eat
and actually went it complemented
everything else so
yeah legend joined very citrusy
very citrusy the little bit grimlock on
top uh lemon zest capers and fresh
flat leaf pastas yeah i prefer my mash a
bit creamier
i know it's healthy it doesn't matter
you're allowed to have creamy mash
the beast fade dry it's um it's been
over cooked for sure and i won't be
paying for it
results for the main course how do you
think you've done i think we got sloppy
as we went along
i think you know some of the food lost a
bit of its flavoring
here's the truth
27 out of 50. slowing up great
ah damn why not unseasoned mash
unseasonable season mash and overdone
beef we panicked there
yeah i did yeah yeah and you know that's
where we broke down in terms of
communication yeah
let's get 50 out of 50 paying oh
now back to the hog hunt
i'm in america on the hunt for wild hog
these destructive but delicious pigs
have so far fled deeper into the forest
but all that was about to change
walk out a little bit there's a pig
inside there right now [ __ ]
yeah christ almighty a hog caught by one
of major tunes traps was in the road
ahead
i haven't got a good look at him but
yeah he's he's a big pig
he does not look happy nope we'll just
shoot him
and uh then we'll have to move back to
the truck get the truck load him up and
then go through the whole process of
preparing him to eat okay
when we get to the cage and that pig
gets out of the cage our
drill will be we'll just jump up on top
of the cage
trapping is a harsh reality but a clean
shot close-up will ensure a humane kill
and the hog's meat won't be spoiled by
any stray bullets christ look at the
size of him
this is [ __ ] nerve-wracking now you
know a pig's natural instinct is to
charge you but we just gotta stay calm
jesus christ
[Applause]
having dispatched the pig we need to
clean it down in the creek before i
learn for the first time
how to butcher it in the wild open him
up more to get his
internal organs out so you can actually
start right there it's
piping haunting huh
you're doing terrific try to keep blade
up so that we don't yeah
puncture this that's the blood
that's his bladder and we don't want
that thing to pop so we didn't taint any
of the meat that's right
and this here all his organs
with the innards out we hang the hogs
carcass from a tree to skin it
you know what you have in your hand
right there gordon that's uh that's one
of those testicles right here
yeah that's a delicacy with a lot of
folks really
mountain oyster so they're cool yeah
god the skin is so tough yeah huh
it is it takes 30 minutes of careful
cuts to remove the skin from the fat
that's my bullet can i have that back
that did it
what the hell so that went right through
there
and with the skin off it becomes
recognizable
you did it at a mountain of amazing cuts
of meat
[Music]
shoulder
that's the philip the chef's delight
i'm amazed how dark it is
next the tenderloin and the hogs ribs
the ribs one of the cheapest but one of
the most delicious
there's the hams there's the hams good
work
great works two hands two loins
two ribs two shoulders we just need to
find some hungry people now yeah
somebody wants to eat some ham that's
not gonna be difficult on this campus no
it won't be
right hog shot hung skinned butchered
the ribs
the line and this amazing little fillet
here
i'm poaching the ribs in a fragrant
stock onions
cloves garlic and chili to give a really
nice color
a large tablespoon of tomato puree as
that cooks
starts to tenderize the ribs boil for 20
minutes
this is the loin that is the rolls royce
of a hog
that's the little fillet tender
delicious you can actually eat that raw
having removed the skin slice the
tenderloin and the fill it into
medallions
i'm making a marinade for the meat with
olive oil salt pepper
lime juice and chili powder the marinade
will tenderize the hog it's gonna be
like eating butter
next the barbecue sauce for the ribs
start off chop the onion
fry the onion and add molasses molasses
is a really nice sort of
dark sugar syrup that gives a body to
the barbecue sauce
a couple of tablespoons of mustard
chilli sauces and cider vinegar
reduce that down not too rich that there
is the right consistency
brush the meat with the barbecue sauce
and grill
literally 35 40 seconds on the line one
and a half to two minutes on the ribs
whilst the meat rests a coleslaw not too
much mayonnaise
nothing worse than a coleslaw you can't
identify what's in here grain mustard
coleslaw
a nice slice of lime a couple of
beautiful ribs
look at that the most amazing hog ribs
with a barbecued loin we need now some
hungry tummies
where are you guys
[Applause]
gentlemen how are we good
very good delicious very good
very good as i say in the uk put more
pork on your fork
yeah outstanding
coming up f word new boy tom parker
bowles eats one of the most
extraordinary foods in the world i'm
chewing a lot to make sure there's
little buggers don't go down my throat
and danny minogue's hairdresser goes
under the knife in my kitchen
[Music]
i can't believe you just did that
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the f word now time for
the recipe challenge and tonight's
challenger is vegetarian danny minogue
really good to see you and if she loses
by the way she promises to eat a big
juicy fillet steak is that right
no oh come on no no no no no no no it's
never gonna happen girl no now what are
you doing sweet
uh i'm doing a risotto i'm gonna do it
with a bit of pumpkin and asparagus
danny's making a pumpkin and asparagus
risotto i'm gonna do a really nice
asparagus risotto this is my key
ingredient asparagus peelings
i'm gonna put them inside the vegetable
stock to give it a really nice flavor
so talk me through the recipe how does
it work neil couldn't have the pumpkin
i'm gonna um
cube this small and uh
put that in the oven just a little bit
of oil salt and pepper
now where did the recipe come from which
australian chef neil perry um
i love neil perry's food rock pool is
it's got ponytails fantastic
i know we've got to get rid of the
ponytail but your hair isn't exactly
you know like should we get christian in
here
your hairdresser yeah my hairdresser
just sorted out tintin come here a
minute what is that
geez just just stay there a second
i can't believe you just did that it's
seriously gonna get how can you come to
the f-word with your own hairdresser
so shallots garlic lemon zest in
and now the rice and this is really
important that we put the rice in
this is called blasting the rice where
you sort of seal the rice
now the laser pan with some white wine
before the stock goes in
right have you got a boyfriend at the
moment
no no and what do you look for in a man
i like someone
who's you know like old-fashioned
high-waisted trousers
right wife teeth that is that ah that's
so
scary
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] it up all jokes apart between
you and i do you and simon cows
seriously get it on
because you're made for one another like
tomato and basil it's the perfect
combination
we've been on a date before we've only
been out we haven't been honest yeah i
was in the restaurant i was cooking the
food
look at that face it looked like a
romantic evening to me anyway what's
wrong with that's nothing wrong going
out for dinner with a friend
huh how'd you get on with sharon
definitely a roller coaster ride uh-huh
until we kind of worked together i
thought she was very like pro-women and
sure i don't know i don't think she
likes other women around
but it must be hard for you to sort of
read her facial expressions on the back
of the botox
next to him like that no yeah i don't
know if she's happy or angry or
you can never tell no right i've got to
concentrate now
asparagus in the risotto yes that starts
to turn the risotto slightly green
with a really nice asparagus flavored
stock now you're in your mid-30s and
you've been very honest and upfront
about the cosmetic surgery you've had
yeah yeah what have you done my floaters
floaters oh oh right spiced rags
i think apart from the float as well
have you done it
no just just just that i have botox
do you think i need botox pull your face
back what would you look like
at the top as well that's all you have
to go through that one
so you just do the sideways ready
it doesn't go back i tell you it doesn't
go back
i don't think they could help you there
i don't think people recognize me
no because i had [ __ ] botox so i'm
gonna finish mine
with i've got that parmesan cheese a
little bit of mascarpone
cream cheese give it a really nice
creamy texture
and then finally a little bit of butter
and then from there
fresh chives dulce latte and sprinkle
with pine nuts
i'm just finishing off with the risotto
adding my
baked pumpkin and then i'm going to put
in some asparagus
then cheese and then you cry
right both risottoes have to simmer for
a bit then we come back and find out
which one has the x factor
mine i don't think so
now tom parker bowles eats the world's
most dangerous cheese
sardinia is a mediterranean island known
for its sandy beaches
blue seas and beautiful earthy
home-cooked food
but for thousands of years the
sardinians have been enjoying a very
unusual food
the secret of which has been passed down
for generations kazu mazu
otherwise known as italian maggot
cheese
[Music]
i'm here with aficio who's going to help
me track down the sardinian delicacy
there are only a handful of people who
know the secrets of making kazumazu
officio's brother francesco runs one of
the few farms left which produces this
extraordinary cheese from sheep's milk
[Applause]
kazumasu is literally a rotten pecorino
cheese
some sardinian pecorinos are so special
they've been given protected designation
of origin status which means like
champagne
they can be made nowhere else on earth
but sadly that's not the case with
kazumazu
so the sheep are perfectly suited to the
island these uh
spacious ships in this island yeah
they're unique in the sense that
they can survive in a very harsh
environment consuming just a little bit
of grass
it's grueling work the sheep have to be
milked twice a day each one producing
two liters ago
that may sound a lot but a cow would
produce 15 times as much
and you always do this your brother
always does this by hand
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
sorry i am crap at this
so at this rate my cheese is going to be
very little i'm told no surprises there
pathetic everything in the creation of
this incredible cheese is meticulous and
hasn't changed for generations
before we make kazumasu we first of all
have to make pecorino cheese
fresh milk from the sheep now we're
going to put the large
large pot okay milk inside yeah
and uh i'm gonna raise the temperature
for the milk around 40 degrees
the kazoo marzu is so unusual that
brussels bureaucrats got the fear and 30
years ago
banned the cheese from being sold first
of all we had a laugh about
it yeah because obviously we thought nah
they can be serious
but unfortunately it looks like quite
serious drama is going on yeah
it's not the cheese it's it's more than
that it's more deep in our
in our bean in our roots that's part of
your history probably exactly it's our
heritage
okay so off the fire it's all ready now
some people think humans shouldn't eat
maggots because they aren't always
killed when they're eaten
in extreme cases they could even tear
holes in the intestine causing vomiting
diarrhoea and bleeding but these maggots
are much smaller than blue bottle ones i
mean it's incredible it's happened in 25
minutes
big chunks of curd and the way mixed in
and now what's happening francesca's
just mixing the hair out of it really
giving it a good
beating
okay so what we're doing very very very
gently
we're pushing the curd together
underneath all this milk you can feel
this sort of lovely
soft soothing curd oh wow look at that
look at that
and that's it that's all that curd
pushed together
[Music]
lastly the cheese is put into pots and
all the liquid is pushed
out
[Music]
francesco well that for the moment that
is the first stage of our pecorino so
it's very exciting i think that's quite
good
our cheese will take three weeks to cure
but francesco has one ready for the next
stage
by cutting off the crust we make the
cheese really inviting to flies
the perfect place to lay their eggs
chopping the top off is like opening the
restaurants like you open your grand
restaurant come on in flies
you know there we are there's stuff just
at the opening day
the cheese is then left for two to three
months in the dark cool hut
by which time the fly's eggs would have
hatched into larvae
this is the moment of magic
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
the pecorino cheese has been transformed
into kazoo marzu
the larvae eat the rotting cheese as
they digest it it passes through their
bodies giving kazumasu
its unique legendary flavor and texture
and what better time to taste it than at
a family gathering
the butterflies are starting to sort of
flutter around in my stomach
my friend here who's gonna you like the
chasm as you see
if she can eat it i've got it otherwise
i'm pathetic
[Applause]
uh look at that you see the little
maggots here all over the place
[Applause]
it develops it's very very rich isn't it
and it goes across the mouth
i mean it's strong and that strength
develops in your mouth
it's stronger and stronger but beautiful
absolutely
salute
[Music]
tom good to see you hi golden how are
you very well thank you how are you
man has beaten maggots right no actually
there's nothing scary about the mics at
all after the first
the time you um you know taste it how
long until you get a clebula health
until you pass them a doctor
i don't know but i'll be coming back to
you i'll tell you when when my gut falls
out one morning you know the thing i
will come straight back to you
but the thing is the long term effects
will not be known for a year i'll say a
really a year or something like that you
know because they're gonna start laying
eggs
they're gonna have a family they've got
the daughter oh it causes a lot of
conversation hasn't it because it's tons
of conditions but it is literally like
caviar i mean it's a caviar
it is a it's a huge delicacy i'm dying
to taste it yeah
jose oh you've got it thank god you've
got something
cool jesus right get back everyone okay
go on
now where are they you see them here
he's desperately trying
to take a slice or a spoon spoon and
this is the bit you want here
the maggots are in there okay cheers
what [ __ ] it's brilliant it's sour the
aftertaste stays for hours
it sticks it has a length it goes off
oh [ __ ] that is a flight that's the fly
that lays magnify
okay i would defend this to the death
basically i mean it's not i wouldn't eat
it every day i wouldn't probably eat it
again on the whole but i understand it's
too late for your wife
no she hates your mom no my mom's
certainly not
really good to see you yes thank you
yeah look after yourself
right time for dessert pear to sand with
vanilla ice cream
[Music]
individual pear to tan straightforward
simple and absolutely
delicious peel cut
core criss-cross and pull out
vanilla star anise
it starts to perfume the pear and in
terms of flavour
is extraordinary pastry
[Music]
[Applause]
now the caramel hot pan sugar
wait to just start smoking butter
rum burn off the alcohol
pears
icing sugar bake
200 degrees 8 to 10 minutes
that's what we're looking for that
really nice caramelized pastry
[Applause]
ice cream the smell is amazing
individual pair to tan with fresh
vanilla and styronese
done
make sure that pace is really nice and
tight yes yeah andy
yeah ever made puff pastry no you can
buy a really good puff pastry
yeah exactly really good no point right
i've got the caramel working
get five wrapped and then i'll hand over
your caramel yes okay cool
butter in
he's ready for the oven now yeah that's
right
here we go
[Music]
coming up will danny be going down under
in the recipe challenge
okay come on then this is a big deal for
me yeah it's a big deal for me
twice and will the cherry olives prove
they've got the x factor in my kitchen
they're making noise man ham and toys
that's the girls on the block
with the nasty curls
welcome back to the f-word now time to
find out which risotto's got the
x-factor are you ready madam
yes are you yeah i'm ready you're
looking very confident dana you know
yeah your smells yeah amazing
a little bit delta large on top now the
idea of the dolce are going on top
as the risotto cools down it melts the
cheese and gives it a really nice flavor
not too strong and look at you
crisscrossed asparagus
twist of yeah pepper they may think
that's a little bit too cheffy and
make this one the winner i'll put them
side by side well done that
looks amazing right jose come back with
the right result
yeah just make sure you smile when you
put them down yes
so here we have our first well andy
i know enjoy
it's got a good bite to it nice and
herby isn't it
yeah your community hurts you can't
really taste the pumpkin
and i think actually the veggies are a
bit crunchy
[Music]
wow cheese
yeah i like the nuts and the cheese the
combination there i'm going to go for
the one with pumpkin um i found the
taste um a lot simpler lighter as well i
found the one without pumpkin the cheese
was
a little bit too overpowering i
preferred the one without the pumpkin
there was more going on and it was a
richer dish my preference basically
i actually prefer the one with pumpkin
it was a bit lighter to the taste and i
liked
the pumpkin was subtle and i like the
crunchy vegetables i have to see
the one without pumpkin i definitely
prefer because it was just all the
flavours were more complimentary
and just worked better as a dish i mean
obviously very different risottos but uh
i think that this one had an extra
dimension to it that the other didn't
have
a bit more accomplished overall
i'm excited look at his face look you
know he's got that i have nothing to
lose you have
everything i don't know but hold on
that's made me feel a lot better
what was the score three two yep
seriously three two
that's a little bit too close for
comfort okay come on then this is a big
deal for me
yeah there's a big deal for me christ
three two to me
or danny come on gordon
yes
yes excellent
down under nil up jordan one hold on
sweet pea one more thing thank you
yes yes [ __ ] off out my kitchen bye
bye darling yes
there's no point in serving a pile of
[ __ ] put it down please okay so watch up
finger on the pastry and up yeah yeah
those two going first yeah they're going
six and four come back to one
thing
well done thank you well done you've
been a brilliant team so far
can you imagine me starting to sing and
then hitting the top ten
on my first album hello have you still
got it
who's that giggle oh got his hands in
his pockets and his
[Applause]
that's the girls on the block with the
nasty curls wearing tattered bra
sucking me into the straws jumping
[Applause]
i really enjoyed the um the crispness of
the pastry against the sort of texture
of the pear
which is nice and soft and then that was
hot compared to the coldness of the ice
cream
honestly it was a really great dessert
it took me about three seconds to eat
it's good absolutely delicious this is
that was the
ice cream and the texture of the ice
cream with the pear was absolutely
fantastic
that was dessert dessert was phenomenal
um simple to do you could do it at home
quite easily
yeah i mean as long as you keep the the
fire low
there was some other large fires going
on back yeah this is blending off the
help of the
alcohol in the rum if you were doing of
course it would have changed your beard
so be careful
stand back that's all right yeah glad
you enjoyed this i trust you're paying
for it
yes absolutely thank you
results of the desserts right josie
let's go
47 out of 3.
[Applause]
yes yes 117 out of 150 customers
that's not too bad well done
sadly that means you're not coming back
but it was a bloody good effort
now do me a favor out of here
[Applause]
you